-Do you love podcasts?
You listen to them?
-Oh, you know
I love them so much.
-Do you have an app?
Do you listen to, like,
podcasts on different app?
-A podcast app, yeah, sure.
It's called Podcast.
-My app is called, like,
Castaway or something.
-Is it really?
-That's the one I use, yeah.
-Why's that?
-I don't know about
the one you're talking about.
-[ Laughs ] It's purple,
and it's, like, made by Apple.
It's called Podcast.
-No, mine's called, like --
-Castaway?
-Castoff or something, yeah.
-Or, like, Blastoff?
-It looks like
an old radio tower
beaming something.
-Oh, beaming knowledge
throughout the world.
-Yeah. I love podcasts.
And I just --
I brought my headphones with me.
-That's great. I'm glad you did.
-Where'd I put them again?
-They're down around your neck,
right there.
-Oh, yeah. Here they are. The --
-They've become a part of you.
You love podcasts so much --
-I love podcasts.
I don't even -- Yeah,
I let it go through my --
to my jaw line.
-Like, jawbone, yeah.
-Yeah, jawbone.
Just rattles my brain
till I get --
-Until the knowledge
pours in, man.
-I just love them.
I think they're the best thing.
It's the best way to pass time
if you're on a walk,
you're going to work.
-Yep, sure.
-You're going --
-On vacation?
-Well, if the CDC allows,
but yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. But yeah. If you're going
for a walk, go to walk to work,
going on the subway.
-Sure.
-You know? Anyways,
podcasts are the best.
So, the other day,
I was scrolling through
my podcast app.
I have the podcast app --
-Blastoff, yeah. Castaway.
-Ooh, Blastoff is a good name.
-Yeah, Blastoff is a good one,
blasting off podcasts.
-Yeah, Blastoff podca--
[ Laughing ] Uh, so, anyways,
I noticed that there's
a lot of obscure podcasts.
-Really?
-Yeah, stuff I've never even
heard of before.
-Oh.
-So now I thought we could
check a few of them out.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Podcasts."
Here we go.
-♪ "Tonight Show Podcasts" ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-Alright, so, now
let's put this in here.
-You're putting the aux cable --
There you go. Yeah, nice.
-Okay, there we go.
So, the first podcast --
-Oh, you're going to listen --
[ Laughs ]
We're not going to --
We can't hear them?
-What's that, now?
-We're not gonna be able
to hear them? Just --
-I have no idea.
Again, this is --
If you have an app at home,
you want to check out
these podcasts, do it.
I'm just going to let you know
which ones are out.
-Wow. Great.
-Yeah, if they come through --
I mean, these are my --
Yeah, these also have --
They're headphones,
but they're --
-Noise canceling.
-No -- For me.
I can't hear anything.
It projects music.
-Oh, okay. [ Laughs ]
So they're like speakers.
-Like wearing a boom box
on your head.
-Little speaker, sure.
-Yeah.
It's like little speakers.
-Like a boom box on your head.
-Yeah, thank you, yeah.
So, this first one here
is a relationship advice show
hosted by President Joe Biden.
-Oh, wow.
-He calls it -- calls it
"The Old Dog and Pony Show
with the Missus or Boy Fella
in Your Life."
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a pretty long title.
-Wow.
-Alright, well, let's give it
a listen. Here we go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
-Again, these are bizarre.
I've never heard
of all of these,
but there's just new ones
I've just heard --
-These are new ones
that you're enamored with.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. You love these podcasts.
-This next podcast here,
this one here --
You know, I'm just gonna move
it -- It's a virtual screen.
-Oh, my gosh.
-So now I can see it.
-Oh. Wow.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my gosh.
You can see the whole list?
You have
the virtual contacts in.
-What's that?
-You have virtual contacts in.
-Well, when the screen's on,
I can't see.
-Oh, I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-I can barely hear you.
I'm going through the --
-Yeah, you're going through --
-Main screen here.
This next podcast
is a scripted murder mystery.
It's called "Cher of Easttown."
-Oh.
-So, Cher is
a hard-boiled detective
in small-town Pennsylvania.
-Wow.
-Let's take a listen to this.
-♪ I can't break through ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I really don't think
you're strong enough, no ♪
♪ Well, I can't do that ♪
-Guys, well, it's an intro.
It goes on.
-Goes on?
-Yeah.
-How many episodes on that one?
-Put that into -- What's that?
-It's just one
75-minute one -- episode.
This next one is called
"The Fast and the Furious
Pitch Room Podcast."
-Oh.
-I guess it gives everyone
a unique behind-the-scenes look
at how they come up with the new
"Fast and Furious" movie ideas.
-Oh.
-Let's check this out.
-Oh, sure. Definitely.
-Yes.
-Yes. Yes.
-Yeah! Yes.
-Yes, explosions.
-Definitely.
-Totally!
-Bald and strong.
-Stronger, balder.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Great.
-This next podcast is called
"Cockpit Talk."
-Oh.
-Apparently they record it
from the cockpit
of a Spirit Airlines flight.
-Wow.
-Mid-flight.
-Mid-flight,
they record a podcast?
-Sounds interesting to me.
-Let's hear it.
-Let's take a listen.
[ Intercom beeps ]
[ Beep, alarm blaring ]
[ Buttons clicking,
overlapping beeping ]
-Warning. Warning. Warning.
-Wow.
-"Warning."
-"Warning. Warning."
-Oh, this next podcast is --
-Oh, you took -- Oh.
-Well, I'm just gonna
do it for this.
-Oh, now it's your brain.
Now it's straight to your brain.
-Yeah, this is like --
I go right --
This is the way to wear them,
actually.
If you -- No one ever reads
the instructions anymore.
-Yeah, exactly.
-If you do,
this is how you're supposed
to wear the headphones.
-Wow.
-They go on your "head."
-They're not called earphones.
They're headphones. Wow.
-Finally, this last podcast
is called
"Gilbert Gottfried Clock."
-Oh.
-Seems pretty self-explanatory.
I guess famous comedian
Gilbert Gottfried
helps tell you the time.
-Oh.
-Oh, you put it
back on your computer.
Now it's back on the screen.
-Let's see what it --
Let's see --
Let's hear --
Let's listen to this.
[ Laughter ]
-There you go. That's it
right there. That's it.
-Great.
-"Tonight Show Podcasts."